hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it's
the 7th of May and you are tuned into
GameSpot news things have gone from bad
to worse for Nintendo as they've just
posted a four hundred and fifty seven
million dollar loss the publisher are
blaming poll we knew sales for the
monumental figure since they've only
sold 0.72 million of them over the last
12 months with lifetime sales currently
sitting at 6 wait 1 7 million units in
comparison the ps4 has sold over 7
million units but has only been out for
around 6 months in the financial
statement Nintendo said the Wii U
Hardware still has a negative impact on
Nintendo's profits owing mainly to its
markdown in the United States and Europe
and unit sales of software which has
high profit margins did not grow
sufficiently on the other side of the
coin the 3d s is continuing to perform
well with hardware sales sitting at 12
point to 4 million the most popular 3ds
game of the year was Pokemon X&Y
followed by Animal Crossing new leaf on
the topic of the 3ds pokemon ruby and
sapphire remakes are going to beat you
out this year pokemon ruby and pokemon
sapphire will be revamped into Pokemon
Omega Ruby and Pokemon alpha sapphire
respectively and both have a release
date in November of 2014 the games are
touted to be a fresh take on the
originals both of which made their
initial debuts more than a decade ago in
2003 the Pokemon company says the new
titles promise to take place through a
dramatic story within a spectacular new
world let me know if this is the remake
you were looking for or not according to
report from the International Data
Corporation the ps4 is going to top the
Xbox one by selling 51 million units by
2016 games industry international was
privy to a preview of the report which
had a bunch of other industry tidbits to
share as well even though they reckon
the ps4 will one-up the Xbox one they
also think that Microsoft's console
could beat Sony's if they decide to
offer up an Xbox one without the Kinect
attached presumably lowering the price
by a fair amount
reducing the presence of a connect by a
hundred percent specifically the firm
have said the presumed unbundling of
connect an Xbox one which should
facilitate rough price parity between it
and the ps4 should lead to a spike in
Xbox one sales assuming the console and
sensor are unbundled in 2015
IDC expects Xbox one to recover and
emerge with the largest install base of
any console in North America by the end
of 2016 the IDC also added that
traditional disk based retail will
continue to decline and that by 2019
over 50% of total game spending across
all consoles will be conducted for
digital channels let me know how much of
the report you buy into and whether you
reckon the Xbox one or the ps4 is going
to win out by 2016 you can drop your
thoughts in that commenting section down
below or on my Twitter where I'm at
chest McDonnell that's all the good
things I have to tell you about today
but tomorrow have a bunch more news so
check back with me then